las vegas reps say the city was duped
when a public pool was rented out it's a
story the i-team first broke after a
pool party
resulted in a shooting now the i-team
has obtained the documents at the center
of the controversy vanessa murphy here
live in studio with an update brian city
reps say the person who rented out the
pool claimed it was for a family reunion
the i-team learned it was actually an
advertised party with tickets to
purchase for admission
and there was also a cash prize for the
best twerker
metro police say the party resulted in
at least one person
opening fire so here are the documents
we obtained
a request to rent out a public pool on
the sunday of memorial day weekend
for a family slash friends reunion with
100 to 150 expected
and a permit issued to rent the pavilion
center pool in summerlin from
3 to 9 p.m for 960 dollars
metro police say just before 9 at night
more than
100 rounds were fired no serious
injuries were reported and metro
along with the atf are working to
identify
people involved the i-team talked with
councilwoman victoria seaman a couple of
days later
she said the city was investigating what
happened on its end
and pool rentals are suspended metro is
asking
anyone with information to contact the
gang unit
or to leave a tip through crime stoppers
that number
is 702-385-5555
the name of the person who rented out
the pool is redacted on the documents
the i-team obtained
however i tracked down the party
organizer on instagram
he would not provide his full name but
he provided
a statement he claims he never filled
out that request
to rent out the pool for a family
reunion he says he deeply apologizes he
is not a gang member of any kind
and he does not plan on throwing any
events
anytime soon we'll put that full
statement at eight newsnow dot com